on a scale of one to ten with one being
the worst version of yourself and ten
being the best where would you rate
yourself
uh three i guess i'm self-aware
okay have you read my book yet not
really no
i apologize you should do don't
apologize for
okay the first rule of being a man is
don't is stop apologizing so much
men apologize for some of the dumbest
ever like i haven't read your book
yet i'm sorry rich
no don't you don't need to apologize for
stuff st
stop saying sorry so much guys saying
sorry makes you look like a beta
okay at this frequency and volume so
on a scale of one to ten you're saying
i'm a three right now
so if you'd read my book you'd you'd
know that women
when they're matching with guys like the
data from the dating app shows that
women that are rated somewhere between a
three to a ten
only swipe right on guys that are eight
and higher
so a legitimate three
possibly with three kids in tow from two
different fathers
that weighs 220 pounds with short purple
hair
with a feminist degree and broke as a
joke
thinks that she deserves a nine
follow me here on this logic so you're
completely wasting your time doing
anything right now
in the state of mind that you're at
seeing yourself as a three
as your value becomes higher like what
are you taking in a school like what are
you trying to do
uh basically i can speak through your
languages
and i have my interests i play guitar
and what
i want to learn in school and what i am
by going after is information technology
studies
to be a programmer or a developer of
some kind okay
got it so at a three out of ten like
would you say that you're an alpha male
or a beta male like
like where would you put yourself i
never seemed for anyone but also
i never had any any
girl like hit me up so i'm in between i
don't know
okay well you've never symptoms what you
said that's good
so i guess you don't throw money to only
fans thoughts
you're not you're not doing any of that
stuff you can rate me i
i give it i give that to you okay good
so
here's here's what my recommendation is
can you see that on the screen
yes do the work yeah right
so that is my third question sorry
continue
okay so before you get to your last
question what
what i would be doing when it comes to
women i mean i i've said this before and
i'll say it again the reason why
you're messing with these single moms
and why they're doing things like
negotiating when intimacy is going to
happen
and expecting a good guy to come along
and
swoop in and take care of some other
mofos kids it's
it's because you're dealing with the
low-hanging fruit because your value is
not high enough
high value men that see
this is the thing that guys keep
forgetting and i've and
i put this in my book and i'll say this
again right now beautiful women are not
a scarce commodity
okay a scarce commodity on the sexual
marketplace
is high value strong virtuous men that
know how to make bank and put a dent in
the universe
that's a scarce commodity and if you
want to be spoiled for choice so that
you're not messing with the low-hanging
fruit like the single mommies making
demands telling you when into me is
going to happen and
how much money you got to pay to take
billy to the chuck e cheese next
friday for his birthday you need to
increase your value
that's where the return on investment is
is doubling down on your own value i'm
not saying don't date women
i'm not saying don't talk to women but
what i'm saying is
if you keep putting this much effort
into trying to understand them
as to why you keep dealing with these
single mommies and why they keep making
demands on when intimacy is going to
happen
you're going to frustrate the crap out
of yourself and you're just going to go
in the wrong direction
you need to take that energy and unplug
it from women
and having these conversations with
these single mommies and plug it into
how do i make some bank how do i become
the lead guitarist of a band how do i
you know basically how do i level myself
up
so if anything paint a picture for
yourself of what that 10 out of 10 guy
looks like
go do that stuff every day
you